oubliez les bombardements les images de
guerre et d'exode la croatie retrouvent
les faveurs des touristes il faut dire
que le pays à quelques sérieux atouts le
soleil les plages de l'adriatique des
îles paradisiaques et les vieilles
pierres de dubrovnik reportage en
croatie
jérôme baugnies frédéric basket c'est
une véritable invasion de touristes dont
bénéficie à nouveau cette année la côte
adriatique dubrovnik devrait en recevoir
un million deux fois plus que l'année
dernière
ils viennent surtout d'italie
d'allemagne et de slovénie
on prévoit que cette année la saison
sera encore meilleure et on espère que
dans deux trois ans on va avoir même
plus que de touristes que c'était avant
rigueur dans l'ensemble de la croatie il
y avait 8 millions de touristes avant
cette guerre dont les traces à dubrovnik
sont à peine visibles bien sûr
l'ascension en téléphérique n'est plus à
l'ordre du jour son point haut était le
poste avancé serbe
mais depuis les joies de la plage ont
pris le dessus de ce côté des balkans on
oublie qu'à 260 km en macédoine
la guerre continue je crois que ça
inquiète mamère plus que moi ce n'est
pas du tourisme de masse je préfère les
plages grande comme celles qu'on trouve
en italie
question prix il y en a pour tous les
goûts de l'hôtel de luxe où ils feront
de nuit à la chambre chez l'habitant tu
qui attire la plupart des jeunes et
coûte dix fois moins 100 francs par
personne au sud de 7000 kilomètres de
côtes déchiquetées dubrovnik est
redevenu cette année une escale pour les
croisières mais aussi pour les
plaisanciers
c'est la bretagne 10 à 20 ans la belle
marina le petit fort tranquille les
petites criques avec personne je crois
qu'il ya
1000 1200 id difficile d'imaginer qu'il
y a dix ans ce secteur était désert et
raisonnée des coups de canon l'afflux
des touristes aujourd'hui c'est aussi le
signe que la croatie a définitivement
tourné la page de la guerre